two countries Austria and it's the other
one hungry right this Hungarian yeah so
like Austria and Hungary that could be
an answer so the way you thought about
this problem was if you think about it
was pretty different from from like
normal search problems you hide this
constraint in your head that oh I have
two countries that are right next to
each other that's one constraint and you
were thinking about or one of them needs
to start with an A so you had a bunch of
constraints when you think about you
have a bunch of constraints when you
think about a problem that that's like
this and that makes it pretty like that
that helps us to use different types of
model that could be pretty different
from state based models so this is more
of a motivating example you're going to
talk about these types of models so so
far we've talked about reflex based
models state based models so I spend
some time talking about search problems
and the piece adversarial games and then
what the plan is to talk about variable
based models specifically constraint
satisfaction problems today and on
Wednesday and then we are going to talk
about Bayesian networks next week so
we'll have three lectures on Bayesian
networks so what's gonna happen is Rita
is going to talk and talk about the CSP
the second lecture of CSP on Wednesday
and then Percy is going to be back next
week talking about Bayesian networks and
I will do the third lecture of Bayesian
networks so I'll be whole mix of us
talking about variable based models
you'll see all views of us so that's
that's apply okay all right so um okay
so going back to our paradigm I saw our
paradigm is starting with modeling so
how do we model various types of
problems and then how do we develop
inference algorithms that try to answer
questions we care about objectives we
care about based on those models and
we've been talking about learning a
little bit so if you have these models
and they're not full models how do we go
about learning learning these models so
so here is just a review of what we have
talked about so far in terms of modeling
we talked about various frameworks like
search problems or MVPs or games so
these were various frameworks that we
had and and we had different objectives
so we had things like minimum cost path
for search problems
or we cared about other things like
maximizing the value of policies for for
MVPs or games so this was kind of some
of the frameworks we talked about in
terms of inference we discuss tree based
algorithms and we discussed we discussed
graph based algorithms so if you
remember backtracking search was the
simplest most naive thing we tried out
to our search problems for for games
like we looked at minimax and expect
Emacs which was also going down a tree
and then you can have more graph based
type algorithms or where you're looking
at a recurrence relationship and an
examples of that are things like dynamic
programming uniform cost search a star
in terms of MVPs and games you look at
value and policy iteration and an in
terms of learning we discussed a few
types of methods for each one of these
frameworks we looked at structured
perceptron Q learning TD learning so so
these are some of the topics that we
have talked about so far so we are
midway through the quarter these are all
the cool things we have learned so far
and these were for state based models
okay
so state based models were kind of cool
and we had a couple of takeaways from
state based model so let's just
summarize like two main takeaways from
state-based models one of the key way
and key takeaways was was that when we
were modeling these these state-based
models we had we had local relationships
so our model would specify these local
interactions and local relationships
that we had between the states so for
example if I wanted to go from s to a my
neighboring state a then I would think
about what would be the cost of going
from s to a so I had this local
relationship between them and the goal
was to do inference and an inference was
more trying to like we had a global
property can I find the shortest path
from some state some other state in this
whole graph so so the idea was let's
actually model and specify these local
relationships and then do inference
where we find globally optimal solutions
so so that was kind of the whole idea of
state-based models and the thing that
they use the thing that they made like
made them powerful was this concept of a
state so so let's just summarize what
state was well a state is a summary of
all past actions
that's sufficient to choose future
actions optimally and and that's how we
define States that how we went about
States okay and and once we had state
when once we had the notion of our state
then our mindset was I'm going to move
through these states through actions so
so I have states that I can think of
them as notes here and I have actions
which where I can think of them as the
edges in this graph and the question is
how do I go through one state to another
state and what is the sequence of
actions I should take so so if you think
about a policy like we were talking
about this sequence of actions and then
the sequence actually matters right like
I would take this action another action
and the goal is let's say for me to go
from here to the door and I would have a
sequence of actions that need to go one
after each other for me to achieve the
task okay
so the type of problems that you want to
talk about today don't have they have a
little bit more structure they don't
really care about ordering and that's
kind of the key difference so so when I
asked that very first question of pick
like two countries one of them the name
of one of them should starts with a the
other one should speak Hungarian and
they're not right next to each other
then the way you think of like all those
constraints all the things that you need
to satisfy you don't really need to like
follow specific order they're a bunch of
constraints and you decide so I all of
them it really doesn't matter to start
from where and then that's kind of the
idea that a variable based models and
we're gonna go through this example
throughout the lecture so the example is
it's a map coloring example so so the
idea is let's say we have a map of
Australia here and Australia has seven
provinces so these are all the provinces
here and what we want to do is we want
to color this map so so the question is
how can we color each of these seven
provinces with three colors I have red
green and blue so that no two
neighboring provinces have the same
color so so that's that's a task we want
to do and and kind of the key idea again
here is the order of things doesn't
matter right I can pick any of them I
pick a color and then just go from there
it doesn't matter like if I'm if I'm it
matters in the sense of the algorithm
side of it things but in terms of the
model it doesn't matter - to include
that so
so here for example this is one possible
solution right I can have the map of
Australia I can have these different
colors like red green and blue for four
different parts of it and no two
neighboring countries have have the same
color so this is one possible solution
that we can get we can have other
solutions to get and our goal is to find
these types of solutions right all right
so so I can think of this as a search
problem I can I can perfectly think of
this as a search 'fat one where let's
say I start with a partial solution and
my partial solution is somehow I have
decided to choose I'm just going to
refer to these provinces by their first
letters so I'm going to choose W a V and
T I'm gonna just make them red and now
what I want to do is I want to figure
out what other colors to use for the
rest of the provinces yeah so I can just
go down like a search tree so my state
here is this partial assignment and I
can go down the search tree and I can
choose Queensland I still as my next
thing and then I'm gonna call her that
red so if I call her that red everything
looks good everything is great so now
I'm looking at Northern Territory so and
T I'm gonna pick the color I'm just
gonna color that green let's see so
color that green then if you look at si
I only have one option for it right
because I've already picked red and I've
already picked green and si is connected
to all these red and greens so so the
only color I can pick for us a so that
is that is all I have then how about NSW
then that has to be green right cuz cuz
I've already picked blue right there so
that has to be green and and here is one
solution so I just went down a search
tree and picked a solution to this
problem I could have picked some other
solution like that decision that I made
over there to make aunty green that was
kind of random right look I can just
pick blue tur so let me just pull there
and then I can just have another
solution that's a perfectly fine
solution and I'll have my way math koi
how about I choose I choose a different
color for Queensland so I decided I
decided to make it red maybe I want to
make it so if I make it blue then and T
has to be green because that's the only
off
I can have and then when I get to
Istanbul you I don't really have any
options SW I have no colors for it that
would work because green is taken ready
sake and blue ii SW is connected to all
three of these that's not really gonna
work how about I choose Queen to be two
queens line to be green same story and
she has to be blue SW I don't really
have a solution for it okay okay so so
this was just going down through this
example assuming it's a search problem I
don't have these states that represent
partial assignments and I'm gonna pick
actions and the actions are going to
just give a coloring to the next to some
next variable here so so the state is
partial assignment of colors to
provinces and the action I'm gonna take
is assign the next on color province to
a compatible color so I can perfectly
think of this problem as a state-based
using state based models using this
particular state in action but but the
thing is there is more structure to the
problem and the structure in this
particular case comes from the fact that
again ordering doesn't matter so so
variable ordering does not really affect
correctness here it's just a bunch of
constraints it doesn't matter in what
order
I'm satisfying that those constraints
and then in addition to that the
variables there they're kind of
interdependent in a local way so so for
example if I just look at Tasmania like
right here it's not connected to
anything so I can just pick whatever
color I want for that and it's not
affecting the rest of my problem so I
don't really need to have some order to
like pick TFS or pick a class right I
can just pick a color for T and it
doesn't affect the rest of the rest of
my system okay so the idea of variable
based models is let's let's kind of make
our models like make how let's make our
models simpler than state based models
let's let's not try to figure out what
is this the state thing that's
sufficient for us to make make decisions
in the future and then pick actions
sequentially let's try to have an easier
language to represent the model of the
problem that kind of looks like this so
so the idea is to come
this new framework and and in this new
framework we're going to have variables
as opposed to state so we're gonna call
these things variables and we're gonna
have assignments to these variables so
so the whole job of modeling is to
figure out what the variables are and
what sort of assignment we're picking
for those variables and this decision of
well what order should I call our things
or what value should I pick for speak
for each province like like that
decision of what order values should I
pick what order variables should I pick
I can push all of that to inference okay
so so it's not going anywhere I'm just
pushing it to nference
so another analogy here is you can think
that you have a difficult problem and
you can have like an ad hoc way of going
about and solving it and an analogy in
programming languages to that it would
be I would be solving it using assembly
language if you look at state based
models you come up with the idea of
state you're doing something something
more general and you're doing a lot of
work and why are you doing that because
you have a higher level abstraction so
when you're using something like state
based models an analogy to that is maybe
you're programming in C so you're moving
the level of abstraction and then we
were using things like variable based
models it's even moving the level of
abstraction it's a little bit higher
it's it's even like programming in
Python so so sure you can do the exact
same thing in c2 but now you have this
higher level of abstraction to think
about problems and that makes your model
much simpler and the order of things
that can become the problem of inference
okay all right everyone happy but why we
want to do state-based we want to
variable base modeling all right so so
I've kind of motivated this but I
haven't really said what it is how we go
about solving it so what I want to do
for the rest of the class is I want to
start formalizing variable based models
but this idea call it factor graphs and
then after that I want to talk a little
bit about inference in the case of
variable based models so specifically
I'm going to talk about dynamic ordering
and arcus inconsistency as ways
heuristics that allows us to solve these
variable based models and then towards
the end I just want to show a couple of
examples
other examples of
why variable based models are so
powerful and where they come in and just
give you some ideas of like some other
examples to look at all right so so that
is the plan for today so so let's let's
start with a simpler example so let's
say that I have three people maybe I can
draw that here so I have three people
person 1 2 3 and each of them they're
gonna choose a color either red or blue
that's what they're gonna do okay and
each of them have a set of constraints
so the idea is maybe this guy really
wants to pick so so really wants to pick
woo maybe this third person prefers to
pick red but maybe he doesn't it's not
like as bad as the sky so prefers red
and maybe we want to make sure that they
pick the same thing the first person the
second person and maybe we want to
ensure that the second person and the
third person
we prefer they pick the same they pick
the same color okay so these are some
sort of constraints almost that I'm
putting on on this example and the way
that we can think about these
constraints that I've just like laid
down and this picture is using this idea
of a factor graph so a factor graph is
going to have a set of variables this is
like analog of states as we talked about
in a state-based models it's going to
have a bunch of variables I'm gonna have
three variables because this person is
gonna pick something this person's gonna
pick another color this last person is
gonna pick a color so I'm gonna have
variables X 1 X 2 X 3 okay let me
actually write down some of these so
we're gonna go over a bunch of
definitions for the first part of the
class at least so we're going to talk
about factor graphs
factor graphs are going to have some
number of variables we're gonna
represent variables with capital letters
so capital X so in that particular
example the variables that I have are x1
x2 and x3 okay and each one of these
variables they're going to they're going
to live in some domain there or either
going to get red or blue right so so
each one of these x i's they're going to
live in some domain so we were gonna say
X I lives in some domain I so in this
particular example the domain is just
red and blue so each one of these x i's
are gonna live in either red or blue and
if I pick a value for them if I like
come in and say well this guy picked red
and this guy picked blue and this guy
picked red then I'm giving an assignment
so that's called an assignment so an
assignment I'm gonna write it with small
X and it's going to tell me you know
what X 1 took and what small means kind
of red or blue so capital means the
actual variable next 2 and X 3 what were
they so maybe for this particular
example
okay so that was variables they live in
a domain and then we can pick an
assignment okay so now I have all these
constraints and I can write those
constraints as something that's called
factors so these factors are going to be
functions that tell me how happy I would
be if this x one takes value red or
value blue so their function so this in
this case F 1 is a function of X 1 so so
I'm gonna write the factor graph needs
factors these factors are fj's there are
some number of them there might be a lot
of them if J's of some
Exce taking some value X I some excite
aching some value X I or some number of
I'm just write the most general form
right now X and these fj's have to be
greater than or equal to zero okay so
they're kind of telling me how happy I
would be right so so here I would have F
1 of X 1 so if I really want this guy to
pick blue then what would be a good
factor to put here what should I say for
F 1 of X 1 so I can write it as an
indicator function making sure that X 1
definitely takes maybe I can write it
like this so so if it is an indicator
function what does it say what does it
tell me if it is an indicator function
if X 1 actually takes blue then the
value of this factor is going to be 1 if
X 1 takes red the value is going to be 0
so I'm kind of treating 0 as this thing
that I don't want and anything above 0
as something that I actually want to get
so so I'm going to have another
constraint this constraint is going to
be F 2 it's a function of X 1 and X 2
that's why it's connected to both of
them so I'm going to draw these squares
as has kind of what showing what the
factors are so so the circles are are my
variables and then and the scores are my
factors these functions that kind of
tell me what are the constraints what
are the things that I need to satisfy so
if 2 is going to somehow encode that
they need to pick the same thing again
it can be maybe an indicator function
making sure this is these two are equal
to each other and maybe I will have a 3
of F 3 is going to be a function of X 2
and X 3 this ensures that sometimes
victus a or sometimes here kind of means
that you can have an indicator function
but maybe if they don't pick the same
thing you wouldn't be too sad so so
maybe don't put 0 for that so it would
be an indicator function plus some
constant that's one way of going about
it and then X 3 is going to be take
prefers red so it's going to have a
factor that says it prefers red okay all
right
so let's look at same thing on a slide
so that's a factor graph so I can
actually look at the values of the
factors maybe F 1 of X 1 maybe what I
want is I want if for that to be equal
to 1 if X 1 to X blue I want that to be
equal to 0 if X 1 picks thread for the 2
they have to agree for the case that
they have to agree then I can define it
as an indicator function where if
they're not equal to each other I'm
gonna get 0 I'm gonna be very unhappy if
they are equal to each other I'm gonna
get 1 so I would be happy and then for
the case that X 2 and X 3 needs to kind
of be equal to each other then maybe we
can do something like an indicator
function plus 2 this means that if they
don't pick the same thing I'll be happy
but like if they pick exactly the same
thing I'm gonna be even happier so I'm
gonna get 3 and then for the last one
similar thing I prefer the last person
to pick red so I'm gonna give it a value
of 2 to that and I'm gonna give one for
the case so so these are my factors so
the good question so question is does a
pack of value matter or is it just like
if it is above 0 or not
in general it does matter like what you
were picking for you're soon going to be
talking about a specific case of
consider a satisfactory graphs where the
0 & 1 is the only thing that's that
matter so I'm not focusing too much on
the exact values it's just if you get 0
that's pretty bad if you get non 0
that's good so I'm treating them like
that cuz soon we were going to talk
about csps constraint satisfaction
problems which are just factor graphs
where you have zeros and ones alright so
so let's try to actually write this up
so here is this environment that you can
play with it if you want alright so here
you can define variables so I have
variable X 1 it can take now your red or
blue X 2 and X 3 similar thing they can
take values red or blue and I have 4
factors so I'm gonna write up what those
there's our factor f1 depends on x1 it's
a function and it's going to return the
result of this indicator and and similar
thing I'm going to define the second
factor also as a function of x1 and x2
and it returns the value of the
indicator and this all these other
factors and then on the right you can
kind of see these factors being
generated so we're going to look at this
environment even more next time when we
talk about more fancier inference
algorithms but for now all right so all
right so what is the factor of F so more
formally a factor graph has a set of
variables x1 through xn and each one of
these variables each one of these x i's
lies in some domain in this case that
red or blue was our domain and then the
factors are going to be f1 through FN we
have M of them in this case let's say
and and each of these factors is just a
function over X that is going to be
greater than or equal to 0 so that's a
factor of f it tells us what are the
things that we really want so let's look
at one example here so in this in this
particular map coloring example the
variables are the provinces that we have
we have seven of them the domain is
going to be red green and blue so those
are the colors that we can take and then
the factors well the factors here are
just going to be telling us that don't
pick the same color for two provinces
that are neighbors so I'm gonna have
factors that are indicators insuring
that we don't give the same value to two
neighboring territories so on so we have
factors that basically connect every
neighboring territory and again the
square here corresponds to each one of
these functions so the question is is
the domain always the same for all
variables it depends on the problem not
really
also we're going to talk about how to
reduce the domain as we go so that's
that's another reason that I'm
emphasizing on the domain because when
we think about the inference algorithm
the domain is not gonna stay the same
throughout if I pick red for example for
waa then and she's not gonna have red
and its domain anymore
so the reason I keep bringing up the
domain is very gonna look at how to
update the domain for that for the
inference algorithm okay all right so
this is a factor graph let's define a
few more things just so we have a common
language to talk about things so so
we're going to find a scope so scope of
a factor is a set of variables it
depends on so it's really simple so so
scope so I'm gonna write scope here
scope so it's just set of variables a
factor it depends on so for example for
this case if I have F 2 it depends on
two variables X 1 and X 2 so the scope
of F 2 it's just X 1 and X 2
so in this order case when we looked at
the map coloring example if we look at F
1 as a factor that tells us W a at NTU
should not have the same color the two
variables that are used or W a ante okay
so that's the scope then now that we
have the scope we can define something
else called arity which is the number of
variables in the scope so each one of
these squares just how many how many
edges is it coming out of it that's
arity so in this case this particular
square depends on two variables it is -
I can have a setting where maybe I have
a factor that depend on three variables
and air it is three I can have a factor
that depends on only one variable then
arity is 1 and if arity is 2 then we
call it we call the fact they're a
binary factor if arity is 1 we call the
factor a unary factor okay so just
common language so we have arity and
then we have which is which is a number
of variables in the scope and then we
have unary factors when air it is 1 or
binary factors and every taste
so for example in this case of map
coloring f1 is a binary factor so in the
case of map coloring all our factors
were binary if you if you look at it go
back to this so I have a bunch of
factors that just say these two
variables should not be equal to each
other so I have a bunch of Winery
factors and that's pretty much the only
thing I have in this case I have a
binary Factory or have a binary factor I
have a unary factor all right okay so so
far so good
so we talked about assignments right
assignments are going to be a setting
where we give actual values to these
variables and an assignment can have a
weight that tells us how good that
assignment is so so remember if factor
tells us how good this particular site
like how happy I would be if X 2 takes
the value and X 3 gets a value a weight
tells me how happy I would be for the
full assignment so so what it is going
to be is like in this case we can we can
look at weight to just be a product of
my factors so I'm gonna write maybe I'll
just write it in front of here so I'm
gonna define weight an assignment X and
the way I'm writing that is I'm just
gonna write it to be a product of s JS j
from 1 through m so i have n factors so
it's going to be f JS of X taking
assignment X ok so for this particular
example we looked at the tables and each
one of these tables represents our
factor but but now if I talk about a
full assignment then I'm looking at what
does so what happens if x1 x2 and x3
take all possible values that they could
be taking so I have 8 possible options
here and then I'm looking at a weight as
a product of all of these factors
multiplied out by each other so so
remember I was saying well 0 is the
thing that I really don't want to have
so if I have a 0 ever like that's super
like hard constraint that I'm trying
to enforce and that makes my weight
equal to 0.so so if x1 ever picks red
that was like a hard constraint rule you
wanted the first person to pick so the
first person picks red then the weight
is going to be equal to zero the other
thing we really wanted was the first and
second person to pick exactly the same
color if they pick different colors then
my second factor is going to be zero
weight of that is equal to zero
otherwise I would have different I would
have different weights maybe the thing I
care about is to maximize the weight so
I'll pick the one the assignment with
the value for so going back to this demo
and why I meant we were just looking at
what we can do is we can basically we've
defined our factor graph and we can
actually step through it and you can
play with this but you can basically get
these two different different
assignments that give you nonzero
weights and you can pick your favorite
so we're gonna talk about various types
of algorithms that allow you to compute
these weights alright okay alright so
weight of an assignment X is just a
product of the factors and then our
objective is to maximize the rate of the
assignment so I what I want to find is
at the end of the day what I want to do
is I want to find an assignment so I
want to find that small X that maximizes
the weight of all right so going back to
the map coloring example so here let's
say that we define all these indicator
factors so if it is an indicator factor
I'm either going to get 0 or 1 I'm not
gonna get anything other than that then
if I have this particular assignment
which kind of looks right then the
weight of that assignment is just going
to be a bunch of ones multiplied by each
other so I'm just gonna get 1 so if I
find a solution to this map coloring
problem the weight of that that
particular assignment is going to be 1 I
could have another assignment where I
don't get
a good solution I had to up two of these
these neighboring territories are going
to be have the same color if they're
both going to be red then in that case
two of my factors are going to be zero
if they're going to be zero the weight
is going to be equal to zero so for this
particular map coloring example where my
factors are just indicators the only
rates I can get or zero or if I get one
I find a solution if I don't get one I
don't find a solution alright so we have
been talking about Factor after these
more general thanks now we are going to
start talking about CSVs constraint
satisfaction problems which are just
factor graphs we're all factors are
called constraints and the factors are
going to take values 0 or 1
ok and the constraint is satisfied if
the factor takes value 1 so we talked
about factor graphs we're gonna talk now
about constraint I'm just gonna write
CSP constraint satisfaction problems CS
B's okay they also have the same
variables as before and we were gonna
pick assignments for them so same thing
Symonds but the factors are going to be
called constraints and these factors
fj's of X or either 0 or 1 and if you
find an assignment where your rate is
equal to 1 then that means that you're
satisfying all your factors and that's
called a consistent assignment so you
have consistency consistent assignment
that is when the weight is equal to 1 if
the weight is equal to 0 then we have an
inconsistent assignment so it's either 0
or 1 you have consistent assignments or
inconsistent assignments okay so an
assignment X is consistent if and only
if the weight of that particular
assignment is 1 that means all the
constraints are
because constraints are just give me one
and zeros I'm multiplying one on zeros
if anything is not satisfied then the
thing is you're all right so so far
summary so far is we have just gone over
a bunch of definitions factor graph is
the more general case of it constraint
satisfaction problems is more of an
all-or-nothing kind of a situation so
you have hard constraints everything is
hard to constraint and then you have so
so for example if you think of math
coloring you can think of that as as a
constraint satisfaction problem because
everything is a hard constraint like you
don't want any to neighboring countries
to have the same color so you're either
going to give one if that constraint is
satisfied or you're going to give 0 if
that's not satisfied you still have
variables factors are called constraints
assignment wait if that is equal to one
we have consistent assignment otherwise
we have an inconsistent it's a more
constraining factor but yeah it is
dr. graff is this big picture CSV is an
instance of a factor graph alright so
that was factor graphs and constraint
satisfaction problems so so let's talk
about how we go about solving these so
how should we find an assignment our
goal is to find an assignment so we have
consistency because if you are talking
about CSPs you want to get rate 1 that
means you want to have an assignment
that's consistent and makes all my
factors 1 so so how do I pick how do I
pick that ok so so let's look at an
example it's just like let's just see
how we would do it normally like if you
wanted to solve this like if I was
solving this I would pick one of these
like one of these notes or variable so I
would pick W a maybe I would say well
let's just pick red see how that goes
with that and then I would go to a
neighboring neighboring node like NC and
I do have a constraint to constraint as
W a NT should not be equal to each other
so the only thing that tells me is that
NT should not be red so I'm just gonna
pick a some color let's just pick green
so then I'm gonna go to some other
neighboring neighboring note so that's
si I have two constraints the two
constraints are as si should not be
equal to W a
not be equal to NT so it shouldn't be
read or it shouldn't be green the only
option I have is blue so I'm gonna set
that equal to boo then I'm gonna go to
cue the only option I have for cue is
red because it's green and blue are
already taken then I'm gonna go to NSW
the only option I have there this green
want to go to V the only option I have
there is red and then I can pick
whatever color I want for tea okay so so
this is a thing that we would probably
do if we were to do this right we would
go over these notes some order and we
would pick colors and some other order
and I know that's important but but the
way we would do it is just just pick
some more day maybe you would have some
lipstick that picks the order and picks
the values and tries to like make the
constraints satisfied so so what we want
to do is we actually want to spend a
little bit of time talking about doing
that and and having actually heuristics
that that tells us what order we should
use we should use for the variables and
what are their values we should pick so
we were gonna talk about a few here is
six mainly this time so so so to do that
we need to define one more things the
last thing I'm gonna define and and
after that talk about the algorithm so
so we're going to define dependent
factors so dependent so a partial
assignment is going to be partially
assigning values to variables in this in
this CSV right so so a partial
assignment for example here could be
that W a needs to be read and only needs
to be green that's a partial assignment
then I can define dependent factors to
be a function of partial assignments and
a new variable X I so let me depend just
write that number different color occurs
X so we have something else called
dependent factors V of X and X i where x
is partial assignment and X I is a new
variable I'm picking and dependent
factors is going to reach
a set of factors it's going to return a
set of factors that that depend on X and
X I so so for example in this particular
case this we said this is a partial
assignment let's say I'm asking what are
the dependent factors of this partial
assignment and si so I'm picking a new
variable on picking si and I'm saying
what are what are the dependent factors
and and these are going to be the
factors that depend on this new thing si
and depend on the partial partial
assignment so it's going to be this
factor and this factor right I'm going
to be factor that says W a is not equal
to si and I'm gonna pick a factor that
tells me NT is not equal to si and that
kind of like the idea of different
factors is that allows me to think about
the next thing I should make next things
I should be worrying about so so if you
remember like tree search algorithm if
you would look at children of some note
here we're gonna look at dependent
factors because those are the factors
the next factors we should we should
care about that that's why I'm defining
this dependent factors all right so so
now this is the algorithm kind I want to
write it up on the board because it
would be good to have it pseudocode so
all right so the algorithm you're gonna
talk about right now is just
backtracking search it's not doing
anything fancy we're gonna talk about
fancier things next time but you have
backtracking search it does the thing
that you expect it to do
so it takes some partial assignment X it
takes the weights that we have so far
and it takes the domains domains of
those variables that I have so far okay
so if X is a complete assignment if you
found a complete assignment then you're
gonna update the best thing we have and
we would return or we would do whatever
you're supposed to do for the problem
right like you might have different
types of problems here like maybe the
question is find one assignment if I
find one complete assignment I can I can
just return maybe I'm looking for
another question which which tells me
count all possible assignments that you
can have so if I'm counting assignments
then I'm just gonna update my counter
and try to find the next assignment so
depending on what the
question is I might want to do different
things but I find my complete assignment
but let's say I find my complete
assignment then I update okay well yeah
um if not then we're going to choose an
unassigned variable so so if X is
complete then then we're gonna choose
and on assigned variable on assigned so
choose a variable choose another side
variable X Y and well how do I do that
I'm gonna talk about a heuristic to do
it so we'll talk about that but let's
say I have some way of figuring out what
is the next variable I'm picking and
then after you've picked a variable
you're gonna pick some value for it
right map coloring you're gonna pick a
province and you're gonna say red so how
do you know it's red like how do you
know about the next value you need to
pick it's red well that comes from
another heuristic which says order
values in domain so values would be red
blue green so ordered the values that
are in domain I of chosen X so you pick
tech in the next I may be the only
colors that you can use right now are
red and blue so so then you're gonna
order red and blue using some heuristics
but maybe some heuristic says you should
use red first and then you do you do
this red first order it in that domain
in that order and then for each of these
values in this order so for each V in
this order you've decided you're gonna
update your weight or you're gonna have
this Delta weight value and the Stealth
await value is going to be product of
your factors okay and these factors are
factors of your partial assignment
whatever you've decided so far maybe you
have assigned two colors for two
territories already and you're looking
at the third one so it's going to be the
partial assignment Union whatever
value you're looking at for this new x.i
that you're trying to pick maybe a color
for and what are these a choice that
you're looking at well these fj's are
going to be the fj's that are in the
dependent factors of the partial
assignment and your variable that's why
we defined dependent factors these are
the factors that we care about these are
like I'm not gonna look at Tasmanian if
I'm not looking yet that part of the
graph I'm just gonna look at the things
that depend on my current partial
assignment and my my ex I okay if Delta
is equal to zero return or I'll continue
zero continue so that means that this
assignment you continue continue this
means that this is particular value that
you have picked just made everything
zero it didn't work so he should try
other things the other thing you're
gonna do is if this value works is
you're gonna update your domain so we're
gonna talk about how to do that that's
the thing that's going to save you save
you time because like you have now found
out that you only need to care about
colors red and blue and you don't need
to worry about green so so dad that's
updating the domain making sure that you
don't need to worry about all the colors
and then after that you're just gonna
backtrack on this new thing backtrack on
this new thing so in this new thing is X
Union you have picked value V for X I so
this is your new assignment you have
extended your assignment like value V
your weight is going to be whatever
weight you started times Delta Delta and
then you have updated your domain so
you're just gonna use domain Prime yeah
domains prime so this is domains of
every one right like domains of all the
other notes alright so so we're gonna
talk about this a little bit more so but
this is the basic of the algorithm okay
so first talk a little bit about
updating your way so so how do we update
domain so one very simple way of
updating domain is is this thing that's
called forward checking which says well
if you pick a color so let's say that
you pick W to be red then just look at
the
rivers of waa and then see if we can
update the domains of them so this is
the simplest thing I can do right like
I've picked waa I've decided W a thread
so the thing that I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna look at the neighbors the
neighbors are NT NSA they cannot be read
so I'm gonna just update their domains
to be read to be blue angry I just draw
for it so that's like the simplest thing
what we do so it may be alright what
option is this forward checking so let's
go further so maybe now I'm at NT I am
deciding NT to be green if I'm deciding
NT to be green I'm gonna look at
neighbors of NT something look at sa and
Q they cannot be green anymore so I'm
gonna drop green I'm gonna look at Q for
whatever reason and Q I'm gonna pick
blue for Q because I want blue for Q and
and then I'm gonna look at the neighbors
and my neighbor si does not have
anything in its domain so I realized
that at this point like this particular
assignment is inconsistent I don't need
to worry about the rest of the notes and
what I'm picking for the rest of the
notes it's kind of like equivalent to
pruning like I don't need to worry about
anything else because I've just found
out that there's this assignment does
not work okay so that's kind of the
whole idea of update in doing so so
forward checking is the idea of doing
one step look ahead so after assigning a
variable X I you want to eliminate
inconsistent values from domains of
excised neighbors so you want to reduce
the domains of Excise neighbors and if
any domain becomes empty then and you
don't recurse on that and then you're in
a site and it's something to notice is
if you're honest signing X I you have to
restore the domains so as you change the
domains if you're honest sign if you're
reciting or green was not the color to
go then alright so the other question
was this heuristic so it's this
heuristic updating domain one way to go
about it is forward checking just update
the neighbors another place that that we
need to pick things wisely it's choosing
the unassigned variable so which one
which which unassigned variable should I
start off so so which variable to look
next and again one heuristic to look at
here is to pick the variable that's the
most constrained variable so so choose
the variable that has the fewest
consistent values so so you're gonna
pick the one that's the most constraint
variable why do we want to do this why
would I pick the most constraint thing
yeah so you're a bit less options and
and the idea is if I'm gonna fail let me
just real early like this is not gonna
work let me just find out that it's not
gonna work early so so that's the whole
idea of it and in this case like if
you're left with this option where we
where we choose red and green here and
now we want to pick what should I look
at Nick's I should be looking at si
because that only has one value so
that's not gonna work like nothing else
is going to work right so so we want to
choose choose a variable that has the
fewest consistent values and again the
reason this works is if we have some
number of constraints in our factor
graph so so these are more general for
factor graphs too like everything I'm
saying is not just about CSPs it's about
factor graphs and then the reason this
works is we have some constraints right
we have we have some what some of these
factors are going to return a zero
because they're going to return us zero
that is why I would like to follow a
heuristic like this because that allows
me to not look at everything so this
this heuristic only gives us benefit if
we have some factors that are
constraints all right so so that's one
heuristic the second question is okay so
now like using most constrained variable
I pick my variable what value am I gonna
pick for it and then for value okay it's
interesting cuz for value you want to
pick the least constraint value so and
then the reason again is you pick the
most constrained variable cuz you wanted
you wanted to know if you're gonna fail
wanted to fail early but now you've
committed to that variable now you're
going with that variable so you might
ask well you have to like a sign of
value for it so you might as well pick
the least constraint variable here to
leave options for for the other
variables around you so so an example
here is and then how can you think about
so that an example here is you're gonna
look at this the setting where what is
it you're picking Q right and and you
want to choose what color to use what
value to use for Q right you can you can
call her to you red
if you call out you red you're gonna do
this for we're checking and if you're
gonna do forward checking you're gonna
update the domains and when you update
the domains you have two options here
two options here two options here so
that could be a measure of consistency
so you have six consistent values if you
decide to use blue for Q what's gonna
happen is you're gonna update and T and
then that's gonna have one value as a is
going to at one value and SW is going to
have two values so you have one plus one
plus two and that's equal to four
consistent values and then you're gonna
you're gonna basically pick the one that
that leaves the most options possible so
you're gonna order the values the colors
values here refers to colors of selected
x i but decreasing number of consistent
values of quality of the domain of
neighbors and then one other thing is
like these heuristics are only going to
work if you are doing forward checking
if you're not updating our domains
they're not gonna give us any benefits
and also another note about this
particular heuristic which is for
ordering the values the only like place
that this is actually going to give us
some benefits and is when you're working
with the espys and when we actually have
everything as constraints because if we
don't you actually need to go through
all the all the values and then figure
out where the value of the factor is for
for that so this is only going to be
beneficial then we have we have
everything is
it's just one so it isn't recurrence
yeah so so depends on what we were doing
right so so that's kind of this part so
the question is are we finding for the
optimal solution I'm finding for a
solution it depends on like that's kind
of this slide if you find a solution and
you're happy with that one solution you
can just like return it here and be
happy if you want to find the best
solution and you need to like iterate
this multiple times then maybe you have
like a counter here that still it keeps
iterating for CSPs you won't find a
solution because we just want to satisfy
the constraint and constraint but if i
have a factor graph I actually want to
optimize my my my weight all right yeah
so so yeah so this are the idea of this
most constraint variable is we must
assign every variable so if you're going
to fail let's just fail early it's kind
of similar to pruning and the idea of
what order we are picking for for values
is we're gonna pick values with least
constraint value so I'm kind of the
reasoning behind that is we've got to
choose some value right like we have to
choose values for all these things so so
true thing so so choose a value that's
the most likely to lead a solution for
everything okay and this is just okay so
so going back to this this algorithm now
we have a heuristic to follow for all
these three different red wines and and
doing so we're just doing backtracking
and then we can update this and then
just go through it and it does it does
find a solution all right so um so now I
want to spend a little bit of time
talking about our consistency so what
our consistency is is just a fancier way
of doing forward checking so we talked
about the heuristic for this one and
here is it for this one the only
algorithm we're talking about today is
this that's the only thing and we said
well in this algorithm we got to update
the domain the way we have been updating
the domain is just looking at the
neighbor
and trying to update the domain using
forward checking so another idea is to
do something slightly better which is
called
our consistency and our consistency
doesn't just look at the neighbors it
goes through the whole the whole the
whole CSB and tries to update the
domains of event like further knows
ahead of us so it doesn't just look at
the neighbors so that that's what this
whole section is gonna be about how to
do our consistency alright so so the
idea of our consistency is let's
eliminate the values from domains so I
have this this giant domain I don't want
to go over all those values yeah I have
a for loop here for all the values if I
can update my domain that's gonna be
much better so let's just try to reduce
branching yeah so so here's an example
so let's say that I have X I and X I
lives and so I'm looking at X I and XJ
and X I takes value the domain of X I is
one two three four and five and then the
domain of XJ is one and two okay so now
what I want to do is I have a constraint
the constraint is X I plus XJ is equal
to four so if this is my current domain
of X I I don't really need to worry
about all these values in X I because
the constraint tells me well five never
works because X I plus XJ has to be 4 so
that's not gonna work this one is not
gonna work the only way for things to
work is to have 3 plus 1 and 2 plus T
and that's it right so so the only
variables that I actually need to worry
about for domains of X I is 2 & 3 not 1
2 3 4 so so what I want to do is I want
to take the domain 1 2 3 4 & 5 and
reduce that to just looking at to it
because those are the only values that I
should actually care about and this can
yeah because this constraint it's kind
of enforcing that okay so an enforcing
our consistency
basically tries to get to this smaller
domain okay so all right so a variable
like sisal is actually formally defined
variable x i's are consistent with some
variable XJ if each each value X I in
the domain of for each value X I in the
domain of X I there exist some exchange
a domain of XJ so so the factor is equal
is not equal to zero so basically it's
ensuring that everything is going to be
consistent so if you're having
consistencies remove things from the
domain of X I so our consistency ensures
that if there are any sort of
inconsistencies between two variables X
I and X J's its let's say star star X I
and it tries to remove from the domains
of X I to make sure that so we start
from one and so we pick X 1 and let me
try all these other variables X J's and
values of them and then we keep like
iterating we've been doing iterate on
over all of them but we got a like pick
one and update the domains of that yeah
yeah so so what we're gonna do is we're
going to just write have a function
enforcing our consistency and it's going
to remove values from domain of I to mix
and make X I are consistent with respect
to some other XJ so the only thing I'm
touching is domain of X I all right so
so what's actually like go over an
example of how this works
pseudocode for it so here's our example
I'm gonna start from W a I'm gonna pick
correct for it okay so that's my current
domain for W a is red if I was doing
forward checking what would I do
I would just look at Auntie on si I
would update the domains of NTN si
so now what I'm gonna do is I've
realized that NTN si their domains are
changed so I'm gonna push them to the to
the same to the same list of things I
have and I'm gonna look at each of them
and see the neighbors of them too so the
arcs that come from them so I'm gonna
look at Auntie well that is right here
actually Susan so so
everything looks consistent there
everything is great I can't update
anything more I'm gonna pick aunty now
let's say I decide aunty is green so
aunt is green I'm gonna look at
neighbours of NT so neighbors of NTR waw
is red everything is great
sa has a green I need to get rid of the
green because it can't be green anymore
you has a green I need to get rid of
that so let's update that so Q and sa
their domains are touched right their
domains have changed so I actually need
to look at them and then see how the
domains of their neighbors are going to
be affected for example I can look at Si
and I can see well si is is blue the
only way for si to be consistent with
the rest of these guys is that they
don't have any so I'm gonna remove blue
from Q + SW + V coz because they cannot
have to be consistent again if si here
is kind of my ex I so I'm sorry it's
actually my ex J so I'm gonna pick x IQ
here and I'm gonna update the domain of
X I so it becomes consistent with Si
right so I'm gonna pick change the
domain of Q get rid of I'm gonna change
the domain of - W get rid of blue I'm
gonna change the domain of V get rid of
okay so what is updated Q is updated and
SW is updated V is updated they're gonna
go to go back and then you're gonna go
through them again and see if if their
neighbors need to be updated okay so
going back to the - - q Q is red and s
w's domain needs to be updated to be
consistent with Q so I'm gonna remove
red and it's double use domain is
touched so so now I gotta go back to me
he's going to become red and T so if I
do like this fool like enforcing our
consistency here I'm gonna end up with
with something that looks like here so
all my domains are kind of pruned and I
have just like have a solution like I
don't need to actually iterate over any
values and this is just done by by
updating the domains and then doing this
our consistency approach rather than
doing backtracking search
so so all of that is done in this step
okay
all right so so if you want to give if
you want to actually so so this whole
like pruning is only like useful right
if you want to find this so like air
solution in a CSP but if you have a
factor of a new actually if you have a
graph you need to actually try out all
these values to see what is the value
you're gonna get for each of each one of
the callers if we did forward checking
instead we actually would have arrived
at the same conclusion taking more steps
like filling marquees if you were doing
forward checking we had to do the like
we actually had to do like like we
wouldn't get to this like you would get
to this much later because because if
you were doing forward checking you just
look at the immediate neighbors you
update the domains and then we would go
to the next like notes in the neighbor
neighbors and do backtracking search
again you're like I'm not having like
called that like I'm here I've updated
my domain and I'm with that scenario and
I haven't called backtracking search yet
alright so yeah so for we're checking is
kind of a simpler version where you're
assigning XJ to be equal to XJ and and
you're enforcing our consistency on all
the neighbors of X I with respect to XJ
our consistency what it does is it
repeatedly well they're different
algorithms that try to do our
consistency the particular algorithm we
were talking about in this class is
called a CSV it's just the most useful
like the most common way of doing our
consistency and what it does is it
repeatedly enforce our consistency on
all the variables so so it goes over
everything but you watch so so what it
does is you're gonna add XJ to your set
then while set is not empty you're gonna
remove an XK from from that set and for
all neighbors let's call them X L of
this this XK that you have picked for
all the neighbors what you're gonna do
is you're gonna call enforce our
consistency on X L with respect to X X K
okay and if your domain is change if you
don't change the domain of domain of L
then you're gonna add that back in and
that's kind of what we were doing in
this previous example look at me we kept
adding the notes back hit so
oh yeah so in terms of complexity of
this algorithm law worst case scenario
it's going to be order of e times T
cubed where E is the number of edges and
D let's say is the maximum number of
values that you can have so the reason
it is that is when you're enforcing our
consistency this line takes order of D
squirt so you have D values for each of
them you have the values you need to
consider all that coming all those
combinations that's these squared you're
you're doing going over all the edges
right so so you have all the edges so
that's easy squirt and another thing to
notice is you're sometimes adding these
things back in the set so why are you
adding them because their domains can be
changed their domains can be changed at
most D times so that's the texture D so
so that's order of e D cubed if you're
interested in it you can look at the
notes for it
that's worst case scenario in general it
doesn't take that long in general like
I'm not going to keep like adding the
same value like a million times like
back in or the same excel back in my set
in general way so much faster alright so
so again it's a heuristic it's not the
best thing in the world like if I like
ideally you would have wanted a c3 to
not return the solution if there doesn't
exist a solution but but here for
example a c3 is not being very effective
here's an example right so you have
these three nodes and let's say you're
left with these domains so blue and red
if you're enforcing our consistency the
domains are now going to change these
domains are very consistent with each
other but but there is no solution that
actually you can find here right because
if you choose blue and red here you
don't really have an option for the
third one
so our consistency is actually not going
to be able to figure out that this
doesn't work and there are more
complicated versions of our consistency
that consider not that go beyond these
binary relationships but they're they're
going to take exponential time so so our
consistency is simple you run it it's
usually useful but it's not going to
find everything for you
huh okay yeah so and I'm kind of the
whole intuition of our consistencies we
were looking at this graph in a local
matter and locally we are trying to like
update our domains to be more efficient
but it's it's not it's not going to give
us a global answer of course it's not
going to give us a global answer because
if you wanted to have a global answer we
had to I consider the relationships of
all our all our constraints with respect
to each other but it's basically making
sure that locally at least everything
looks good when you should so in general
you can so I would in general I would
say use eighty-three because it's going
to proven things usually if you have a
lot of dependencies between like if you
have if you have like the circle or type
of dependencies it's not gonna figure
everything out but it's usually just
going to be useful so running it in
practice it doesn't take that long
running it is usually going to prune are
the part of your domain so we recommend
using it but it's not going to figure
out everything because you have you have
connected like everything is going and
everything is connected with everything
then you have dependencies between all
your variables all right okay so so
sorry so far is well we've been talking
about backtracking search on partial
assignment we talked about dynamic
ordering so how to order our variables
and how to order our values we decided
to order our variables based on the most
constrained variable because if you're
failing you want to fail early and we
decided to order our values like if I'm
picking red blue or green based on the
least constrained value because if
you're if you have decided to be a value
we should try to succeed so that's kind
of the intuition behind it and look at
is useful for we're checking is one way
of doing it so it enforces our
consistency only our neighbors are
consistent consistent ac3 enforces our
consistency on neighbors and their
neighbors and just goes over all the
arcs in the graph all right so that was
kind of a set of algorithms I wanted to
talk about but next time we're going to
talk about more more and friends and
learning type types type algorithms for
CSP so now what I want to
I want to spend a little bit of time
talking about modeling so you've talked
about two examples that write the map
the map coloring and this one is also
like picking colors you said these are
the examples you have talked about so
far so let's look at another example so
so let's say that we have three
sculptures a B and C and they gotta be
exhibited in a museum we're in an art
gallery
and I have room 1 & 2 so they can be
either in Rome one or room two and I'm
going to have a set of constraints so
maybe my constraints are sculpture a and
B cannot be in the same room sculpture B
and C must be in the same room and room
to can only hold one sculpture so so
these are my constraints how would I go
about this well I need to write a bunch
of factors I need to write I need to
actually so let's try to do this so this
was my domain so I have three sculptures
so I'm gonna define variable a all right
so that's sculpture a it can be in room
one or two okay then I have three
sculptures so I'm gonna have variable B
and variable C each one of them can be
in Rome one or two yeah so now I gotta
define factors right I had all these
constraints one of the constraints was a
and B cannot be in the same room so so
that's a factor yeah let's call that F
fun it's going to depend on a and B
right cannot a and B cannot be in the
same room but is that factor it's a
function right over a and B and that
function is going to return something
what should it return it should return a
not being equal to B okay so that's one
factor what else do I need just make
sure okay here so so far what I've done
is I've defined a B and C they can take
values 1 & 2 have defined one factor
that connects a I'm gonna define another
factor f2 that
is going to connect B and C and I really
want to sculpt her B and C to be in the
same so what I want is B and C to be
equal to each other yes it could be the
same
so that's factors F 2 that's just
created here and what was the last thing
I want it yeah so every room get one
right second room okay second room only
get only gets one so that's a factor
that depends off on all three of them
right it depends on a B and C and one
way to enforce that is what I'm gonna
say is well if a is in two or if B is
into season two right so I'm gonna I'm
gonna write indicator functions if is
into B's into season two and if I add
those up well that should be what that
should be less than or equal to 1 right
because I don't want to be more than one
of them in in so okay I have this third
factor this third factor is not a binary
factor anymore right it depends on all
three of them
and then if I step then we're going to
talk about these algorithms next time
but here is assignment that that you're
gonna find so we're gonna find that
sculptor a is going to be in room 2 B is
going to be in room 1 and that size wise
all the factors so if you're interested
in writing up more models use this
environment so that was another example
of C ESPYs so now I want to talk about
one more example so I think two more
examples okay so this is an event
scheduling example so so the event
schedule example is I have events but
say these are classes different courses
that you're taking and then you have T
times
lots so you have e events and t
timeslots yeah
and you want to schedule you want to
schedule a time slot for an event that
that's what your plan is so it's a
scheduling problem anyhow I watch of
constraint so the first constraint is
each event must be put in exactly one
time slot so each event in exactly one
time slot one time T so that's one
constraint another constraint that you
want to have is maybe you want each time
slot T to hold at most one event because
we don't want them to overlap so each
time slot T you want that can have at
most at most one event event and then
maybe I have a set
maybe maybe event E is allowed in time
slots T only if event E and time slot T
are in some set that someone gave me
some a set so I have another constraint
that ensures that some e with its time
slot is in some predefined okay so these
are some of the constraints that I have
and what I want to do is I want to I
want to formulate this problem as a CSV
so so how would I go about it what
should be my variables so you're going
to go over the events okay so let's say
that so we can actually have multiple
formulations for this so one formulation
may be the most natural formulation here
is to say that my variables are going to
be events so those are going to be my X
is here and every event can take a
timeslot so the value that it's going to
get is 1 through T where T is the time
we have T different time slots okay so
then if I if I start with this if I
start with a setting
but I'm saying every event is a variable
then I kind of get this first constraint
for free so each event E is and isn't
exactly one time slot because I have my
variables e they're not going to get
multiple values assigned to them they're
gonna get one assignment so if I if they
get one assignment I kind of already get
this one for free the second constraint
is this constraint which makes sure that
each time slot can have at most one
event so so to ensure that then I need
to make sure that X is not equal to any
some other XD prime right because
because X E is my variable my event
variable its gonna get a time time slot
value the two times thought values for
two different events should not be equal
to each other so the constraint that I
have is X is not equal to XD prime XD
prime okay and and how many of these do
I have oh I have like order of e squared
of them because I have events so I have
so then I have e times e options here to
make sure that they're not equal equal
to each other
so I have e squared binary factors okay
so I know I have another constraint
which tries to ensure that these these
events and their time slots which is the
x value is going to be in some set a you
can kind of treat this as a unary factor
so you have some number of unary factors
you have any unary factors here yeah so
and then the number of variables that
you have is the number of variables you
have is e but their domain is size T so
it's good to think about that these if
you have multiple choices so I'm gonna
talk about the second choice in a second
but if you have multiple choices for
modeling this it's a good idea to think
about what type of factors do you have
how many of them do you have so here are
like the worst case scenarios I have a
squirt binary factors so I have another
option right so this option what I did
was I took the events as my variable the
second way to formulate this is to say
well maybe my variables are just the
time slots so maybe I'm gonna go a
different different approach take a
different approach for modeling this I'm
gonna call it YT
I see are the times so I have variables
for timeslots each one of them can
either take an event or maybe there's no
event at it that's empty empty you so so
they either take an event or no event
and if I model this this problem using
using the second approach then I get the
second the second one the second
constraint for free because my variables
are again time slots so I can I can I
can satisfy the second constraint and
then for the first constraint I actually
need to write something for the first
constraint which says each event is in
exactly one time slot so I'm gonna write
a constraint that says YT this time slot
is going to get an event for exactly one
T so this particular constraint that I
have it's it's how many variables does
it have if I want it to be exactly one
time slot remember the sculpture example
I wanted to be exactly in one room
you needed to depend on everything else
so this is going to be a cheer you can
straight right so I have T variables
here so previous formulation
everything was binary or unary here I
have a tea or you can straight have less
of it but I have it Eureka straight okay
and then I'm gonna have another
constraint to just ensure this this last
this last so so one way to think about
these two different approaches is how
many of these constraints do I have so
so we just saw that we have it's here
you constraint here one thing that you
can actually do and I have a slide
afterwards about that is if we have some
can some N or you can some tea or you
can strain some constraint that depends
on T number of variables I can actually
change that to order of tea winery
constraints so I can actually like
reduce down to binary constraints so so
I can make these two algorithms another
make these two models to have all binary
or you know registry so that part is
fine but what one of them is going to
have T number like order of T a number
of factors the other one is going to
have order e type factors and and the
question is well which one should we use
and it really depends on if your is
greater than T or T is greater than E
right so so if you have if you have more
time slots than events you've got a lot
of time slots and you have
like five events let's say that you want
you wanting point set then you should
use the first algorithm because that
that was where we had order of e squared
number of constraints but if you added
the other way around which is again less
natural but maybe you don't want to you
don't want to Euro cave it not assigning
all events a time slot so so if you're
if you have it the other way around then
then you can use the second formulation
so so the point of it is you might have
different ways of formulating a problem
you should use the one that that is the
most beneficial depending on what how
many constraints you have and then one
last thing to before before we head out
so I just said if you have an NRI
constraint we can actually write down
binary constraints that are equivalents
to this and the reason is usually our
algorithms require having binary or
unary constraints here I haven't have a
setting where I have this or between X 1
X 2 X 3 and X 4 so the way to make this
make the binary constraint is what we
can do is we can define an auxilary
variable so so I'm gonna define a new
variable and this new variable I'm gonna
call these a ice and these a ice are
going to be just the result of the or of
a I minus 1 or X okay so so what what's
happening here is it's real quick so I
have a setting so I had X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4
I can have an energy constraint that
connects all of these together to one
one factor graph what I can do is I can
actually define new variables so I'm
defining that many new variables a 2 a 3
a 4 and then I'm ensuring and I'm
defining new factors where a 1 is the
result of these tours so I'm gonna just
draw this like this a 2 is the result of
our of these two variables a 3 is the
result of our of these variables and so
on this is not binary right what is
there a 3 so we need to do
one more step like after we were
defining these auxiliary variables after
that we need to define we need to do one
more step where we define a new variable
B which kind of represents AI and AI
minus one so I'm going to replace these
two you're just one variable we call it
v1 and I'm gonna just connect that to
get the idea so the eyes are just going
to be representing AI and that allows me
to have binary binary factors here okay
and then Y doing so I'm adding actually
one more constraint I actually need to
add a consistency constraint that makes
sure bi minus one of two is equal to bi
minus vbi my just ensuring that like pre
and post are staying the same as we move
away through that graph alright let's
add next time